Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are looking at what you might often hear as hindsight being 20-20 vision. And I'm asking myself the question about the five things that I wish I'd
这些原则都同样适用。Lisa本人还会直接提供丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨人们常说的“事后诸葛亮”（hindsight is 20-20 vision）。我问了自己一个问题：有哪五件事是我希望在本科心理学学习期间就知道的？
known as an undergraduate psychology student. It's going to be a journey through personal and professional reflections and I hope it is one that you will find so useful. Stay tuned because it's coming up right now. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent Hello, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So, what are we up to today? Well today we are going to be looking at the five things, five top things I wish I had known as a psychology undergraduate student. I think this is a really
这将是一段充满个人和职业反思的旅程，我希望这对你也会非常有帮助。请保持关注，因为节目马上开始。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这档播客成为你的指南吧。有这档播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。那么，我们今天要做什么呢？今天我们要探讨我希望在心理学本科期间就知道的五件最重要的事。我认为这是一个非常
interesting conversation to have and I hope that some of my reflections might well help you. Maybe if you're an earlier stage of your career, or even if you're a similar or maybe even a more advanced stage of your career. These are in no particular order. These are just my general musings. If you are watching on YouTube, please do take a moment to subscribe, like the video, maybe pop a comment in, share it with your friends. And yeah, with no further ado, let's crack on with number one. it is possible to do a sandwich course or a placement course, basically to get out there into the world and do some psychology before I was graduated. I think that would have been really, really useful for me in learning more about what psychology is, how it translates in the real world. And it probably would have fueled my fire to know more explicitly during my undergrad which direction
有趣的对话，希望我的一些反思能对你有所帮助。也许你正处于职业生涯的早期阶段，或者处于相似甚至更高级的阶段。这些内容没有特定的顺序，只是我的一些随感。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请花点时间订阅、点赞视频，或许可以留下评论并分享给你的朋友。好了，废话不多说，让我们从第一点开始。其实可以参加三明治课程（sandwich course）或实习课程，也就是在毕业前走出去，做一些心理学相关的工作。我认为这对我了解心理学是什么、它如何在现实世界中转化非常有帮助。这可能会激发我的热情，让我在本科期间更明确地知道自己
I wanted to go in. When I was working in the NHS, we would sometimes have people come in and do summer placements with us from their psychology degree, or we'd have master's level students coming in to do a clinical placement in sort of clinical applications of psychology. But I know that had I tried, or had I known to try, that I could have sorted out something myself, maybe even using one of the days that I wasn't in university so I know in my first and second year I have Wednesdays and Thursdays off I could technically one of those days to do like an honorary placement one day a week for a whole year and that would have paid me rich dividends as it was in my second and third year
想往哪个方向发展。当我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时，有时会有心理学专业的学生来我们这里进行暑期实习，或者有硕士生来做临床心理学应用的临床实习。但我知道，如果我尝试过，或者知道可以尝试，我本可以自己安排一些事情，甚至利用我没课的日子。我知道大一和大二时我周三和周四没课，理论上我可以利用其中一天，一年里每周做一天无薪实习，那对我大二和大三会有巨大的回报。
and I did end up working in a clinically relevant setting but that's a story for another episode because I kind of wish I'd had something you know more explicitly psychology perhaps within a psychology team because that certainly wasn't what I had when I was doing my paid work. So point number two comes to me pretty regularly, I have to say. So in the work that I do talking to and supporting aspiring psychologists, I often get to learn of the research that people have done at undergraduate level. And I'm often blown away by how brilliant it sounds, by how, you know, clinically useful, clinically interesting, how robust it sounds like their research was, you know, using proper, proper methodology, proper research methods research methods you know maybe using granite
我最终确实在临床相关环境中工作过，但那是另一集的故事了。我有点希望当时能做一些更明确的心理学工作，比如在心理学团队内部，因为我做带薪工作时显然不是这样。第二点我经常想到。在支持有抱负的心理学家的工作中，我经常了解到人们在本科阶段所做的研究。我常常被他们的研究听起来有多出色、多有临床价值、多有趣、多严谨所震撼，他们使用了非常正规的方法论，比如扎根
theory or ipa or you know getting your your spss crunching for something more quantitative um and it just makes me shudder a little bit to what me and my cohort sort of got away with university undergrad research I mean it was a it was an interesting concept um so my undergrad research was looking at um baby facedness of people and whether their smiling or unsmiling faces affected how people kind of saw them and rated them. And, you know, it is all right, you know, as a piece of social psychology, but when I compare it to what other people were doing, you know, it's poles apart. And I guess with that, you know, as part of point two, I would say, I wish I'd taken myself more seriously. You know, I wish I'd really had a think about myself as a psychology researcher, and ultimately as a psychology professional, that's going to have a
理论、解释现象学分析（IPA），或者用SPSS进行更定量的分析。想到我和我的同学在本科研究中“混”过去的方式，我不禁打了个寒颤。那是一个有趣的概念。我的本科研究是观察人们的“娃娃脸”特征，以及他们微笑或不微笑的脸是否影响人们对他们的看法和评价。这作为社会心理学研究还可以，但当我把它与别人所做的相比时，简直是天差地别。我想作为第二点的一部分，我想说，我希望当时能更认真地对待自己。我希望我真的把自己看作一名心理学研究者，并最终看作一名心理学专业人士，因为我将拥有
career beyond this three years in psychology because of course we can't know that when we're at university um but I wish I'd really known more about research before going on to create my own um you know so when I was at a level we'd start to do psychology tests and write them up as little research projects and that felt kind of cool but really I don't think my undergrad research really was much more advanced than that other than I had a slightly wider sample survey but even then my sample survey was just people that I met around the university campus so you know the population of my research was highly skewed because they were all hanging out on the campus really or were friends of friends living with people that I already knew so it was highly
超越这三年心理学学习的职业生涯。当然，我们在大学时无法预知这一点，但我希望在开始自己的研究之前，能对研究有更多的了解。在A-level阶段，我们开始做心理学测试并将其写成小研究项目，那感觉很酷，但说实话，我不认为我的本科研究比那先进多少，除了样本量稍微大了一点。但即便如此，我的样本也只是我在校园里遇到的人，所以我的研究人群高度偏颇，因为他们要么都在校园里闲逛，要么是我已经认识的人的朋友的朋友，所以它非常
skewed so I wish I'd taken myself more seriously immersed myself more in research and done something a little bit more robust at my undergraduate level. Point number three was something that only really came to me in about 2007 which was five years after I graduated. And it's something that I commonly introduce people to, maybe as part of my aspiring psychologist membership, or in any of my compassionate Q&A sessions that I run, that you have an interesting useful valid voice to be able to get things published before you qualify I think I had the idea that it's only professionally qualified psychologists who have anything interesting to say that I might want to read or you know other people might want to read but you know publications know, publications such as, you know, psychology magazines do need
偏颇。所以我希望我当时能更认真地对待自己，更深入地沉浸在研究中，在本科阶段做一些更严谨的事情。第三点是我直到2007年才意识到的，那是我毕业五年后。这是我经常向人们介绍的内容，也许是作为我“有抱负的心理学家会员”的一部分，或者在我举办的任何富有同情心的问答环节中。那就是：在获得资格之前，你也有一个有趣、有用且有效的发言权来发表文章。我想我当时认为只有专业合格的心理学家才有值得一读的内容，但实际上，心理学杂志确实需要
content from people at a range of career expectations. And so I wish I'd cottoned on to that a little bit sooner. I will be back along with my two final points about the things I wish I'd known before I graduated. I'll be back very soon. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. Lovely. Thank you for listening to that. Hope you like that little song. Yeah, do grab yourself a copy of the Clinical Psychologist Collective and for that matter, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective because they're rather good.
来自不同职业期望阶段的人的内容。所以我希望我能早点意识到这一点。我稍后会回来分享关于毕业前希望知道的最后两点。很快回来。有这么多技巧和经验可以学习，有这么多事情可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。很好，谢谢你听那首歌。是的，一定要去买一本《临床心理学家集体》，还有《有抱负的心理学家集体》，因为它们真的很棒。
And that's, you know, following on from that point that we did before the break, that is a way that aspiring psychologists did get publications before they became professionally qualified as well. So, yeah, thinking outside the box can pay rich dividends for you in terms of your CV and your expertise. So with no further ado, let's have a look at my fourth point for the things that I wish I'd known before I graduated. So I wish I'd really known and taken on board that it's a ask for help. You know, if things aren't coming naturally to me, or if I feel like I just need a little bit more consolidation a little bit more of a thorough understanding as I was learning or of the way to help that be translated in the essays I was writing and also that it's not geeky
接着刚才休息前的话题，这也是有抱负的心理学家在获得专业资格之前获得发表机会的一种方式。所以，跳出思维定式在简历和专业知识方面能为你带来丰厚的回报。废话不多说，让我们来看看我希望在毕业前知道的第四点。我希望我当时真的知道并接受这一点：那就是寻求帮助。如果事情对我来说不是自然而然的，或者如果我觉得在学习过程中需要更多的巩固、更透彻的理解，或者需要帮助将这些理解转化为我写的论文，那么寻求帮助是没问题的，而且这并不书呆子气。
a study you know so when I was at secondary school I was often called a boff it might not be a term that's used anymore a boffin um because I found learning relatively straightforward and I often knew the answers but because it was used as a criticism as an insult I guess it made me think it was not cool to be brainy, you know, that that was not an okay thing to do. And so when I found myself on the rare occasion that I was in the library studying, I didn't feel like that was cool, you know, at university. I felt like that was a really sad thing to do and that people thought I was sad. But of course, I was there to get an undergraduate degree. And of course, studying is quite important for doing that. And so I wish I'd just given myself permission to really lean into that and to, you know,
学习。我在中学时常被称为“书呆子”（boffin），这可能不再是一个常用的词了，因为我发现学习相对简单，而且我经常知道答案。但因为这被用作批评和侮辱，我想这让我觉得聪明并不酷，那不是一件可以接受的事情。所以当我在大学里偶尔在图书馆学习时，我觉得那并不酷。我觉得那是一件很可悲的事情，别人会觉得我很可悲。但当然，我去那里是为了获得本科学位，学习对于实现这一目标非常重要。所以我希望我当时能给自己许可，真正投入其中，
to play that psychology undergraduate schema to the max, really. I probably planned my time a little bit better use my diary better probably didn't even have a diary in those days um just to plan in my deadlines and to really think about maximizing my time so that I had a you know a better experience ultimately with higher grades but asking for that support and perhaps asking for some of that accountability so that perhaps maps on a little bit to to our most recent episode which was episode 103 where I was talking about the times I've failed in psychology in my life so if that resonates with you do check out that episode as well
最大限度地利用心理学本科生的身份。我本可以更好地规划时间，更好地使用日记本——那时候我甚至可能没有日记本——来规划截止日期，并真正考虑最大化我的时间，从而最终获得更好的体验和更高的成绩。寻求支持，或许寻求一些问责机制，这可能与我们最近的一集（第103集）有点关联，我在那一集中谈到了我一生中在心理学方面失败的时刻。如果这引起了你的共鸣，也请务必查看那一集。
so point four was a little bit of a double-handed point and point five is a little bit of a of a double as well but six or seven things I wish I'd known as an undergrad psychologist might not be quite as catchy as five so yeah I've sort of um I've cobbled two together, but, you know, I wish I'd known how transformational compassion focused therapy was going to be to me, both as an individual, but also as a professional. I wish I'd picked up some books about that sooner. And I will link in the show notes to the books I think have really, really helped me and helped my understanding, which in turn have helped shape my clients and their experience, but also has given me a much gentler journey on myself since I started embracing that. And of course, it's helped me have the name for the free compassionate Q&A series, which I run across my socials at psychology application form
所以第四点是一个双重观点，第五点也是一个双重观点。不过“我希望在本科心理学期间知道的六七件事”可能不如“五件事”那么朗朗上口，所以我把两点合并了。我希望我当时知道“同情聚焦疗法”（Compassion Focused Therapy）对我个人和职业生涯会有多么大的变革性。我希望我能早点读到关于这方面的书。我会在节目说明中链接我认为真正帮助了我、帮助我理解的书籍，这些书籍反过来帮助塑造了我的客户和他们的体验，也让我在开始拥抱它之后，对自己有了更温柔的旅程。当然，它也帮助我为我在社交媒体上（心理学申请表）运行的免费同情问答系列命名。
and psychology interview stages as well. So if you feel like you could do a little bit more compassion, do consider coming across to my YouTube channel and watching some of those free Q&A series. Some of my advice has been collated as well into a free DeclinSci guide, which you can get by, if you're watching on YouTube, scanning the QR code, which is on screen now, and then following the link to download your free DeclinSci guide, which is all about, you know, top tips for your application form and i know that
以及心理学面试阶段。所以如果你觉得你需要多一点同情心，请考虑访问我的YouTube频道，观看那些免费的问答系列。我的一些建议也被整理成了一份免费的DeclinSci指南，如果你正在YouTube上观看，可以通过扫描屏幕上的二维码，然后点击链接下载你的免费DeclinSci指南。它全是关于申请表的顶级技巧，我知道
this season has now passed for applications but it's never too early to start thinking about future applications and to think about just you know making sure that when it comes to interviews that you're going to be able to to talk about yourself and your experiences. And the Declan Sci Guide is great for that too. If you are not watching on YouTube, and so you cannot see the QR code, if you go to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk, and then head along to the tab that says free resources,
这个申请季节已经过去了，但开始考虑未来的申请永远不嫌早，只需确保在面试时能够谈论自己和经历即可。Declan Sci指南在这方面也非常棒。如果你不是在YouTube上观看，因此看不到二维码，你可以访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后前往标有“免费资源”的标签页，
you will see it there. The second part of that is linked to my compassionate journey I wish I'd known that I won't get assistant psychologist jobs straight from graduation I know it's possible some people do and if you've had a placement year it's more likely that you will get that but I didn't. And of course, I found myself in a slightly weird position where I felt the pressure to apply for those, even though I didn't have the time to do a job if I got the job. So I found myself looking for and applying for assistant psychologist job roles when I was actually saving up to go traveling.
你就会在那里看到它。第二部分与我的同情之旅有关。我希望我当时知道我不会在毕业后直接得到助理心理学家的工作。我知道这是可能的，有些人做到了，如果你有一年的实习经历，你更有可能得到它，但我没有。当然，我发现自己处于一个有点奇怪的境地，我感到申请这些职位的压力，即使我如果得到了工作也没有时间去做。所以我发现自己在攒钱去旅行的时候，还在寻找和申请助理心理学家的职位。
And so I don't know why I did that you know why didn't I just lean into my experiences of working as a home carer and as doing temping I think I just felt that pressure to to use my degree and to do something advanced to where I was going to go yeah ultimately but that wasn't what that stage of my career was about that stage of my career was about earning enough money so that I could go backpacking around the world for six months and that was enough you know um and I still think about those experiences of that time around the world as being really, really nourishing. I still draw on some of those memories. You know, I was talking about it in the episode where I was talking about driving recently.
我不知道我为什么要那样做。为什么我不直接利用我作为家庭护理员和做临时工的经历呢？我想我只是感到压力，想要利用我的学位，做一些先进的事情，去我最终要去的地方。但那并不是我职业生涯那个阶段的重点。我职业生涯那个阶段的重点是赚足够的钱，这样我就可以去环游世界六个月，这就足够了。我仍然会想起那段环游世界的经历，觉得它们非常滋养。我仍然会借鉴其中的一些记忆。你知道，我在最近谈论开车的那一集中提到过。
My experience is being on Fraser Island, driving around on the sand island there. Really, really great experiences. You know, I've seen some beautiful sights. I've met some wonderful people, made wonderful memories. and that was what that stage of my career was about it wasn't about getting an assistant psychologist post I wish I'd given myself permission to just do what I was doing then without that need to do something relevant okay so we've reached the end of my five forward slash seven top things I wish I'd known as a psychology undergraduate. I'd love to know how this resonates with you, whether it's similar, whether it's different to what you wish you'd known, or maybe you're an
我在弗雷泽岛（Fraser Island）的经历，在那里的沙岛上开车。非常棒的经历。我见过一些美丽的风景，遇到了一些很棒的人，留下了美好的回忆。那才是那个阶段我职业生涯的重点，而不是获得助理心理学家的职位。我希望我当时能给自己许可，去做我当时正在做的事情，而不需要做一些相关的事情。好了，我们已经讲完了我希望在心理学本科期间知道的五分之七件事。我很想知道这是否引起了你的共鸣，是相似的，还是与你希望知道的不同，或者也许你现在就是一名
undergraduate psychologist right now. I'd love to know what you think maybe you're heading towards doing your psychology undergraduate soon um you know let me know come and connect with me on socials which you can do by scanning the qr code on your screen um or you can and or you can come along to my free facebook group the aspiring psychologist community with dr mar Marianne Trent. And do consider coming along and joining us in the Aspiring Psychologist membership too, because wonderful things happen in there. I hope you found this episode helpful. I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will be along to you from 6am on Monday.
心理学本科生。我很想知道你的想法，也许你很快就要去读心理学本科了。让我知道，通过扫描屏幕上的二维码与我在社交媒体上联系，或者你可以加入我的免费Facebook群组“有抱负的心理学家社区，与Marianne Trent博士一起”。也请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”，因为那里会发生美妙的事情。希望你觉得这一集有帮助。我期待在下一集《有抱负的心理学家播客》中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。
Thank you so much for being part of my world. See you soon. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical psychologist collective book i found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong
非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。很快再见。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这档播客成为你的指南吧。有这档播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Yana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有成为心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，
and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。